hello everyone and welcome to CH at we
are graciously hosted by the cloud on
our team who hosts these amazing weekly
webinars so definitely make sure you
tune in to cloud on air every week my
name is Nick Orlov and I'm a customer
engineer at Google cloud and today I'm
absolutely thrilled to have one of the
Rockstar product managers of Google for
dr. Joshi productor you want to
introduce yourself sure thanks Nick
hi everyone really excited to be here I
work in cloud networking I'm a product
manager there I work on several
networking products including load
balancing CDN and others but most
interested to be here today to talk to
you about cloud armor yeah absolutely
you know security is always top of mind
for every one of our customers whether
you are a small start-up or a massive
enterprise security is absolutely
foundational to your success as a
business and one of the unique things
that Google brings to our customers is
that Google is a tried-and-true player
in this market and we obviously see
these kinds of security threats
vulnerabilities from end to end and so
our approach to security since we've
done this before is to absolutely trust
nothing that's really how everything can
be boiled down sir and the way that we
approach security is a very
defense-in-depth manners rather than
just protecting the perimeter we really
protect all edges of us all layers of
the security stack so whether that means
using our custom-built hardware that's
in our data centers to I am security
permissions for your end users security
keys encryption keys we really make sure
that your data that is being sent to
Google cloud is being protected end to
end and today I'm really excited because
we get to talk about the subjects of the
application and the network itself
because those are very very critical
components so that's your doctor can you
run us through some of that sure happy
to
so as Nick mentioned at Google one of
the first things that we do is we trust
nothing and which means that you have to
secure everything in the stack and as we
start talking about network security it
is very critical to secure every pass
every resource and every access that can
happen when you're actually running your
services inside Google cloud or even on
Prem accessing it from elsewhere and so
on now if you look here what you notice
is that there are
Pat's mmm first of all you have your V
pcs in Google Cloud and you would
typically use a firewall so these are
our distributed firewalls that run on
the hosts
if you're connecting let's say from
on-prem or even if you're accessing any
of the Google services such as Google
Cloud Storage bigquery and so on there
is another feature called VPC service
controls which helps you with access
control to that but one of the areas
that is typically of concern to almost
everyone who's delivering
internet-facing services is how to
mitigate and defend against denial of
service attacks and how to protect your
internet facing applications from
getting attacked or even just from
unauthorized access as well so most of
what we are going to talk about today is
related to that and that's where first
of all our network and some of the other
products including cloud armor come in
the picture great I'm excited so you
know the other day we were talking about
the denial of service attacks and a good
way to essentially slice these denial of
service attacks is think of them and as
being in separate buckets the first one
is the infrastructure DDoS attacks so
this is where an attacker will try and
send you huge volumes of traffic and
will try and overwhelm your application
so examples and could include TCP syn
floods our DNS ntp and other
amplification attacks things such as IP
fragmentation attacks and so on these
literally require tons and tons of
bandwidth to mitigate now there's
another more sophisticated form of
attacks which are called application of
air attacks these not only not
necessarily depend on volume but they
depend on being aware of the application
and then exploiting the weakness of the
application so examples would be
slowloris cross-site scripting SQL
injection and so on and then the last
one would be a lot of these attackers
are very sophisticated and they are
essentially combining multiple types of
attacks and then that's what we call the
multi vector attack I love that Google
is protecting not only the
infrastructure itself but also the
applications would you mind going into
just real briefly what cross-site
scripting and sequel injection are oh
sure so
as I mentioned before they depend the
attacker depends on knowing something
about the application in both cases the
attacker is trying to inject some
malicious code and making that code
execute because that's that's a weakness
in the application so for example in
case of SQL injection the attacker is
trying to take the flow of SQL and
trying to execute queries against the
database
so imagine dumping out the whole
database for the attacker that's what
you would do in SQL injection in case of
cross-site scripting similar but you're
essentially injecting malicious code and
making your browser execute a set of
things against the application so
imagine bypassing access controls knobs
and so on so that's what you would do
with cross-site scripting definitely a
threat for sure so as we started
thinking about you know as we had our
own services so we started off with
search and there's YouTube and this
Gmail we have about 7 billion user plus
services and we definitely get attacked
a lot so one of the first things that we
did as we put these services in place is
to also build out the infrastructure to
go defend these services against our
denial of service attacks now if you
look at the graph on the screen this is
a statistic that is gathered from all of
the attacks that have been seen on
Google's own services a few interesting
things I wanted to point out now if you
notice the graph is already in T bps and
traditionally you've seen these graphs
and Mbps so these attacks have already
surpassed and like gone into the TV PS
territory so internally we have updated
all our graphs to be TPP has driven the
same increase can be seen along packets
per second and some of the other metrics
as well the second thing actually do you
wanna have something I was just gonna
comp that it's absolutely incredible
that things are scaling up so quickly
now that this the the the predominant
predominance of these attacks are really
growing in scale so that's just
incredible that's true and in fact
Damien who is one of our DDoS defense
leads he gave me this really interesting
statistic he said you know what does a
big DDoS attack feel like or look like
or how much bandwidth does it require
and he said imagine it's like basically
requiring
bandwidth needed to watch half a million
YouTube videos at the same time in HD so
in this massive amount of bandwidth that
is needed on the provider side to go
absorb these of attacks and also defend
the services against these attacks as
well yeah if you're a start-up or really
any size company I could see how trying
to play millions of or half-a-million
YouTube videos simultaneously would
bring down your network that's true
that's true
so a lot of times when the customers are
onboarding into GCP the first question
they have is what are the kind of
protections that are there or what are
the products and solutions that are
there to help defend their internet
facing services think of them as being
in two categories the first is the set
of products that we ourselves provide
the first one being the global network
you'll talk about it a bit more
there's the global load balancer we have
cloud CDN and then cloud armor which is
a product we launched in March we also
have an interesting product called
identity aware proxy which we will talk
about soon as well and a very
interesting one along with all of this
is project shield which is essentially
our pro bono service uses the same
infrastructure but it's used for
defending journalists and other folks
who essentially you know are voicing
opinions that would likely be suppressed
and that's why they're getting ddosed so
they get basically shielded under
project shield we also have several
partners who provide capabilities for
DDoS defense you can see some of them
listed on the screen we have a lot more
so the whole idea is to give you an
arsenal of tools that you can actually
use to go and build really comprehensive
protection for your internet facing
services so let's let's maybe walk
through each of these and dissect them a
little bit not really one of the things
that you will typically hear from
customers who are Google cloud customers
is the biggest reason they chose Google
cloud is its network and when you look
at this diagram this is essentially
showing you Google's network if you look
at all of the blobs with numbers in it
those are our regions and then the
numbers in it are the number of zones in
that region so that's where you'd put
your compute or your store
the some of the things that you
mentioned when you were talking about
defense and depth that entire stack is
secured when you're deploying things in
here the second interesting bit in here
is all of those blue lines so that's
essentially our network this is our
backbone these are tables could be under
C could be terrestrial the dark grey
dots that you see are our pops and so
the pops are where your customers come
and terminate their traffic and then
from there they are connected to the
data centers the regions and zones that
you see using those blue lines so those
are our cables undersea terrestrial and
so on
one of the interesting bits that I also
like to tell is a network is also
shark-proof so this is an actual picture
of so windy we looked at those blue
lines that's actually one of those
cables
it looks like the shark was hungry but
luckily there was no downtime on any of
the services being served there so it is
actually a pretty phenomenal network and
it is also one of the big
differentiators as to why customers come
to Google cloud so having this you know
huge global network that's the reason we
can deliver all of the services that
then go and secure your services as well
awesome so we spoke about the
infrastructure one of the first things
that customers who come to Google cloud
do is turn on the global load balancer
now if you think of traditional load
balancing which is essentially weather
itself managed or delivered by third
parties that would reside inside the
data center because you're running it as
managed VMs or you're running it as
managed containers one of the nice
things about our global load balancing
is it is not essentially delivered
through VMs or through containers but
it's this massive globally distributed
infrastructure that sits at the edge of
our network and so anytime you put the
global load balancer in front of your
back ends which is instances or storage
that's sitting inside our data centers
you're essentially stopping the
attackers you're stopping the malicious
traffic right at the edge of the network
and you're preventing that from
consuming bandwidth all the way to your
backends of course this is the same
infrastructure that again our defense
Google's own services
so it is battle-tested over the last
decade or more and the last thing I
wanted to mention is Google is a big
believer in TLS everywhere and so
generally we encourage all of our
customers to use TLS so you use HTTPS
for non HTTP traffic we have other
flavors of load balancers that will
support it but that is one of the big
things where you know we've always been
a been a big proponent of TLS everywhere
we introduced several new features to
help make that easy so things such as
SSL policies multiple certs we don't
charge anything extra for TLS so it is a
huge driver for you to go and deploy
your services with encryption turned on
that's awesome and I know that
performance is very critical to Google
and so one of the amazing things that
customers like about our load balancer
solution is that there's absolutely no
pre-warming required basically we scale
with you as your traffic scales traffic
skills up yeah and I think to your point
I mean the reason we can do all of
pieces these are just architected to be
massively distributed systems and they
benefit from economies of scale as well
so given that you know these can handle
YouTube's worth of traffic or search
worth of traffic it is very easy for us
to also provide the same amount same
scale or even the same high availability
to the customers that actually go and
use this core which brings us to the
main topic for today which is cloud
armor so we spoke about the network and
we spoke about the global load balancer
as being your first line of defense
including against volumetric and
protocol attacks so your infrastructure
DDoS defense when we provided these two
we used to often hear from our customers
so is there a way for me to go put a
blacklist or whitelist or can I go
control access to my service if it's
coming from a certain Geo can I go drop
that traffic or can you help me put some
sort of vassals
at least started hearing more and more
of those requests that is how this
product cloud armor was born we also
used to hear from our partners about the
requirement for something like this will
deep dive into that so again when you
see when we say whether it's the global
load balancer or cloud armor the
infrastructure
is used to deliver these products exists
has existed for decades decade or more
and what we give you is a way to go and
orchestrate this infrastructure so you
can use it to protect your own services
so it's a really good combination where
you have Google's global network you
have the cloud load balancer and then
cloud armor is a service that today is
supported with HTTP HTTPS load balancer
will be supported with other services as
well so the other key thing is it is
basically defense at scale which means
you don't have to worry about how many
queries per second you this cloud armor
think in support because the thing
itself is so distributed that it will
scale up based on your traffic so you
don't have to worry about the Itchy of
cloud armor itself and then the last
thing we wanted to build is essentially
a policy driven framework so build a
very robust policy driven framework that
then you can go build on to deliver
security policies or a block certain
type of things or even build your own
custom rules and so on so that it isn't
in a nutshell as cloud armor one of the
things that I also mentioned briefly is
that it works with the global HTTP HTTPS
load balancer so that's what you can see
in here which means that the
infrastructure DDoS defense is taken
care of by the global HTTP HTTPS load
balancer and then several of the other
capabilities that we spoke about will be
taken care of by cloud armor but one of
the things I thought is you know it's
one thing to talk about cloud armor why
don't we go show it in action
sure let's do that I'm excited hi
everyone welcome to our demo on denial
of service today we are going to show
our top retailer defense against denial
of service attack today's black friday
and give some
deals on our website and we have a
number of shoppers for up early in the
morning to shop on our website the boxes
represent our happy shoppers across the
globe and their shopping on our website
and buying products now if you look at
this one this is essentially our
shopping app and the baskets essentially
are servicing all of the transactions
that are coming in you can see the lofty
box is floating in across the globe
coming into our service and you can see
a bunch of happy shoppers who put some
really great deals there's the thing
this is also a prime opportunity for an
attacker to go launch an infrastructure
DDoS attack look at the screen you can
see some really happy shoppers shopping
but with infrastructure DDoS attack the
attacker stems and tons and tons of Tor
traffic trying to overwhelm our shopping
service and in fact if you look at some
of the largest attacks that we've seen
at Google you can see that they're
increasing exponentially in volume and
in fact if you looked at all of these
attacks they are like watching half a
million YouTube videos all at the same
time in high-definition
look at those attack packets coming in
they would have totally overwhelmed our
shopping service and our shoppers would
not be able to shop at all but we were
prepared for this try at a Black Friday
we have deployed Google global load
balancing you can see the beautiful blue
ring this is Google's global
infrastructure that's protecting our
shopping app and making sure that all of
our customers in shop happily you can
see that all the infrastructure DDoS
attacks are mitigated and we have some
happy shoppers
however infrastructure DDoS attacks are
not the only attacks you're gonna see
James one of the other more common
application level attacks that we
encounter is known as sequel injection
now here in this picture you can see the
happy packets coming in and fulfilling
orders but a sequel injection once that
begins it is problematic for two
important reasons important reason
number one we have a DDoS attack where
it's trying to actually deny service but
more importantly in these types of
attacks your data could potentially also
be at risk so coming back here to our
big screen you can see the happy packets
coming in but you can see here the
sequel injection attacks coming in and
interfering with the orders on my
servers as they're going through here
now both volumetric and sequel injection
attacks are things that we can plan for
when we design our application so today
we're happy to announce cloud armor
cloud armor has sequel injection rules
that allow us to deploy in advance when
this is deployed we can go out and
mitigate these types of attacks before
they ever endanger our application both
volumetric attacks and simple injection
attacks are ones that we can plan for
when we design our application there are
more sophisticated attacks that require
a reactive approach one of these we're
going to demonstrate is going to be a
multi vector attack
someone favorite vector attacks are very
interesting
you have attackers who use one or more
or even multiple types of attacks to try
and overwhelm your service so let's look
at other service you can see that
without Black Friday shoppers we have
the legitimate traffic but we also have
malicious traffic that has some
interesting characteristics look at the
bottom half of the screen what you
notice in the tiny island in the ocean
is a botnet attack now this attack has
three interesting characteristics first
it is originating from the small island
second the traffic that's coming in has
this really specific signature inside
the packet in the traffic and the third
thing is that it's coming in from a
specific type of browser we can do
something really useful with this one we
talked about cloud armor which provides
your application level defense it also
is underpinned by a very sophisticated
rules language that lets you build
custom rules and so what we are going to
do now to make sure a wrap skateboard is
to build a custom rule so when we deploy
the custom rule
what's final happiness the cloud armor
is going to look for a specific pattern
which is the specific signature the
specific browser and then also ensuring
that this is only traffic coming from
that specific Island this way you ensure
that none of your legitimate traffic is
blocked out but your attackers are so
here we launched the cloud our custom
rule you can notice that the bottleneck
attack has been easily mitigated against
everything looks good our shopping app
is happy and most importantly our users
are happy we have an excellent Black
Friday we've made tons of profit we are
now going to go ship all of this
products to our happy shoppers and with
all of that we introduce you to two
interesting products the global load
balancer and cloud armors and we have an
arsenal of other products from our
partners so with all of these products
we hope you build a comprehensive
solution happy shopping and happy
keeping up your services up and running
thank you
and we are back to being live well
productive thanks so much for showing
the video I think it gave a really good
high level understanding of how cloud
armor works and I think it's
demonstrated how relevant this product
is as you saw in the example the the
retailer who basically has to deliver a
bunch of products on Black Friday and we
all know that Black Friday can be one of
the most critical days of the year for
polling and revenue I was able to
protect their services using cloud armor
so whether you're a retailer or whether
you're a gaming company or what have you
I can definitely see that this would be
applicable so very exciting now
productive can we go into some of the
nuts and bolts of how the policies work
I knew you would ask that
I'm sure yeah so as you rightly pointed
out first of all it is critical for all
customers whether you're a retailer
gaming customer and so on but what I
wanted to do next was to give a little
bit of a peek under the hood and explain
how is it that the framework is built
out and especially explained by what we
mean as a policy driven defense or
policy driven DDoS defense absolutely so
the way cloud armor is laid out is as a
set of policies if you look at this
policy as an example the name of the
policy there are three policies in there
you can see you can probably read the
three policies in there now when you
think of a policy think of it as a
hierarchy of rules if you look on the
right-hand side you can notice that
there is a set of rules at the end is
always a default rule each rule itself
comprised is comprised of a match
condition and or a set of match
conditions and then you'll have some
actions that you'll take on that as well
and then you can take this cloud armor
policy and you can go and connect it or
attach it to one or more of your
services so the moment you do that
that's when cloud armor kicks in for
your services you could choose to have a
custom policy per service or you could
essentially go and put the same policy
across all of your services so it's up
to you interesting this is a closer look
at what's inside a cloud armor rule so
we spoke about the policy being
comprised of rule inside the rule
essentially you have a match condition
and this could have either one match
condition or there could be a set of
match conditions once the traffic
matches this signature you obviously
want to tell us what you want to do with
the traffic so you know it could be a
variety of actions in there as well you
also want to tell us where this rule
should be inserted inside the hierarchy
so that is what the priority tells you
preview is again another interesting
feature where if you enable preview then
whatever action would have been taken
essentially gets locked but you do cloud
armor it doesn't actually take that
action oh that's great
you can actually see what's gonna happen
exactly and imagine you want to try out
a rule so that is when you would go and
configure it in the preview mode we we
wanted to pick a framework for
specifying these rules using something
that will be open source as well as
something that's in use by some of our
other security products and that is why
we picked what is called the common
expressions language cell it is hosted
on github so you can actually take a
closer look at it as well but the entire
specification of cloud armor rules is
you've done using that and firebase
customers if you are an existing
firebase customer you've probably
already used it as well yeah I've got a
couple questions actually
so first mean I see that the actions
allow either allow or deny which is a
little bit binary and I imagine that
some customers would be interested in
something like throttling and a rate
limiting is that something that you guys
are considering and in product
management oh yes that's a great
question so today you can do allow deny
you can also specify the codes with deny
and we are actively working on adding
rate limiting as well awesome I'd also
my customers are going to be excited
yeah I think I think it's a pretty
useful feature for a lot of customers
cool and then I also wanted to ask for
the common expression language how
complex is that is that something that
anyone can just get going from the
get-go or does it involve some training
some complexity actually it is fairly
straightforward are very intuitive to
use and we are also publishing in the
cloud AMA documentation the rules for
what you typically want to do having
said that it has a lot a lot of features
which actually let me show you what's in
Oracle so let's take a closer look at
that when you when you think of cloud
I'm a rules language the first thing is
what are the things to look for inside
the trap
and to specify those you typically want
to look at IP addresses whether they are
v4 or v6 the HTTP headers for example
you may want to look at the geolocation
of the client so each of these that you
see essentially is looking at those
specific things inside the traffic okay
that would be your attribute or your set
of attributes the second thing you
typically want to do is combine one or
more attributes and that's where your
pre does kick in so imagine this IP
address and not that geo so that's where
you use the operator and and also not
and then the last thing is we have a
very sophisticated set of operations so
for example actually it's not listed
here but you can even do things such as
regular expressions you can do is lower
you can do uppers so there's a whole set
of operations that you can do to build
out really rich routes and it'll which
ones of these you use depends on what it
is that you're trying to accomplish so
that's roughly what it looks like it's
fairly human readable we will provide
you an editor inside our UI so Pantheon
UI and if you want to automate it you
have the g-cloud CLI and API as well
right so and and then you know as time
goes by we'll try and give you as many
pre-canned rules as we can so you don't
really have to even look at the language
if you choose not to love it cool so
let's run through some of the use cases
that drove creation of cloud armor the
most popular use case that we initially
started with was essentially blacklist
and whitelist for your traffic in this
example our customer wants to only allow
let's say traffic from 9 9 9 0 / 24 so
you would put a rule which looks for
that IP and then you would put whatever
action it is that you want to take this
could be their allowed this could be
deny or you could and you could also
turn it on in the preview mode as well
this is supported both for ipv4 and ipv6
because our global load balancer
supports ipv6 clients as well and then
this this could typically are very
likely in many cases this specific
condition could be combined with other
conditions as well one of the most
popular uses usage of this specific
feature is if you're using a third-party
service are you using one of our partner
services and let's say you're scrubbing
your traffic through the
without this feature even if you strap
the traffic through the partner you need
something at the edge of our network
which says only allow traffic in from
the partner and deny all other traffic
that's not scrub through their partner
so this is where you would also leverage
the whitelist feature and that's one of
the most popular use cases for this one
okay the other popular one is geo based
access control so you want to bring in
essentially traffic from certain Gio's
and block from other Gio's this is where
again you would use cloud armor with
checking for the region code which
checks for the geo you don't have to
worry about the IPS and so on you just
specify the code which is the iso
alpha-2 code so in this case it's using
a region code as us so it takes away a
whole lot of toil from your end in
mapping any IPS to geo you just use geo
directly the third one which is again
another popular use case is customers
asking for a flight functionality more
specifically for defense against
application of air attacks things that
just cross cross-site scripting or SQL
injection that we spoke about and we
have pre-canned rules for it so you
don't need to worry about how to craft
the difference for it as you can see
it's a single rule which in this case is
for SQL injection and there's a similar
rule for cross-site scripting and then
we'll continue to add to this rule set
so you don't have to worry about
crafting these rules on your end the
fourth one is what you saw before when
we did the nice black friday demo in
this case what you're essentially doing
is taking a set of parameters and you're
crafting your own custom rules these
could be 4d0 attacks these could be for
customized access for your services and
we have several partners who are
actually using this to build out their
own products as well so there are
several use cases for this this language
and in this case it's looking for
traffic that's originating from us
where the user agent contains bad part
and also the cookie is a specific value
and it's likely going to drop that
traffic awesome yeah that's always on on
everyone's mind is how do we prevent
zero-day attacks and yeah that's
something very difficult to accomplish
so I'm glad that Google's gotten into it
yeah this is actually building out the
framework
the whole thing is anytime
want to defend against an attack you
need to be able to craft these really
are custom signatures and to do that
first of all you need a very flexible
language where you can express what it
is that you want to block so this this
actually goes a long way in doing that
also one of the things is when you
actually do all of this you do want to
make sure that you're able to see what
is blocked or what is allowed and we
show these we are stacked driver logs so
if you zoomed in on this one what it's
doing is this was essentially an SQL
injection attack that was blocked and it
is telling you that the action taken was
deny it tells you what policy was
matched it also tells you the priority
which basically maps to the rule that
blocked it and then it also gives a
string which is denied by security
policy which gives you some more
additional details about the block
itself so this is very critical because
a lot of customers would want to see
what is blocked and what is allowed and
then also to see that the policies are
working as intended the last one is
actually a very interesting use case and
we have another product called identity
aware proxy and that will essentially
work with user identities and will tell
you if the traffic is authenticated so
can they access a service or not so it's
basically identity based access control
the nice thing is that it is it works
with the HTTP HTTPS load balancer and so
you can use it in conjunction with cloud
armor so imagine you wanted to say
something to the effect of only let the
traffic in if let's say the user is
coming from us and the user is
authenticated or has been it's allowed
to access the service based on identity
and that is when you would turn on both
cloud Armour and identity aware proxy
and it gives you a really rich set of
again rules that you can deploy to see
what kind of access control you want to
do so you can layer on like think of it
as the stack right you've got layer 3
layer 4 layer 7 and with identity aware
proxy working in conjunction with cloud
armor you're you have a layer X on top
which is essentially identity so it's a
very powerful stack that you have at
your disposal yeah I can definitely see
how this would be incredibly applicable
for companies that might have employees
who are going on the road
getting into airplanes traveling etc
because it'd be really difficult to say
alright this employee only accept their
IP address when they're in in California
but when they go on a sales sales trip
would be difficult to kind of change the
rules automatically so the combination
of cloud armor plus the identity where
approximately just makes it incredibly
powerful that's true that's [ __ ] so I
hear you have a demo for us so yeah
because I knew you'd ask me a question
sir I have it ready so what I want you
to do is are we we showed you what it
looks like from a customer's perspective
using the Black Friday example we showed
you some of the constructs that actually
a makeup cloud armor what I want you to
show you is the demo and then also show
you a little bit of the configuration or
under the hood so I thought we should
pick let's pick the three typical
attacks that you can expect customers to
be worried about okay and so if let's go
back in here okay so the first one
essentially is DDoS attack now in this
case the way we have set it up is we
have two projects one is the attacker
project one is the defender project in
the attacker project and we have set up
this tool called Metasploit and some of
our own homegrown systems to go launch
attacks the other side and the defender
project is where we'll go and configure
a set of things to defend against the
attacks so the first one is an
infrastructure DDoS attack now let's go
to the defense side if you notice the
red thing that is basically your attack
traffic and you can see that the things
like you can see that line go up and
these are real real data points not yes
and I'll show you the stuff behind them
very cool now if you look at this one if
you look in here all we need to do for
this one is turn on the global HTTP
HTTPS load balancer that's all this
command does so when I click it you can
notice that the load balancer got
deployed and you can see that the line
is essentially going down which means
that attack traffic is going down it's
now almost mitigated the second attack
if you remember we spoke about was SQL
injection now again this is using the
tool this is not as much about volume
but essentially just exploiting the SQL
set of traffic and then injecting your
malicious stuff in there
so again Metasploit generates an SQL
injection attack and on the defense side
this is where cloud armor kicks in so
what when we click that button what it's
going to deploy is a security policy
which is turning all essentially the SQL
injection defense hmm so let's turn that
on and you can notice that the attack
traffic has gone down mm-hmm the last
one is the one that we spoke about
earlier which is the multi vector attack
so you could have either infrastructure
and this or you could have different
types of attacks within a single attack
or from a single entity and let's let's
launch this attack in here let's assume
that this attack the signature of the
attack is traffic coming in from us with
user agent bad bot and then a specific
type of cookie so we would put in a rule
that actually does these three things
looks for these three things and ID
denies the traffic so again the red is
the attacker traffic and when I deny
this you can see that the attack traffic
is going down so the attack is mitigated
and that's just to show that this is all
real let me show you the project that
sits behind this so this is the defender
side of things this is these are a stack
driver logs so when you look in here you
can see what is getting locked in here
and then you know basically what
happened etc so this is where you look
at those locks that we spoke about and
then the actual configuration would be
somewhere in here where if you go to the
networking side of things this is
security policies is where all of these
policies are actually configured and you
know there's a bunch of interesting
stuff to do in there especially if you
start configuring rules when we spoke
about the rules language this is the
Advanced Mode and this is where you
would go and use the language to create
your rules about real-time protection
yeah so this is so this is actually
where you know it basically is the time
where I ask you the question and I say
mix so what do you think of cloud armor
I think it's an incredibly powerful
product is definitely one of the amazing
tools that we can put in our customers
tool belt of security
protection tools and so what I really
took away was four key things first
being cloud armor does a phenomenal job
of mitigating DDoS attacks and whether
that's just a TCP syn flood
amplification attacks or fragmentation
attacks we really have our customers
back and make sure that they're
protected also I love that the complex
or the comprehensive rules allow you to
protect on all sorts of different areas
so whether it's specific to IP address
geolocation custom matches l3 through l7
it's very enabling to give this to our
customers and let them create and set
their own rules also I really like that
this not only defends on that the
infrastructure attacks but also
application attacks that Google supports
our customers and their applications
that they're trying to run and then
lastly what solution would would exist
without some kind of way of monitoring
and making sure that what what you've
deployed is actually working so I love
that this is real time and we can enable
our customers to do that ok that's great
and so that brings us to almost the end
of the presentation we wanted to make
sure you had a look at you know the the
load balancer of the network cloud armor
but I think our biggest endorsements
generally always come from seeing
customers actually use use these
products and then find value in the
products and Evernote in fact in 20s
2016 are moved to Google cloud and one
of the strong drivers for there was that
they could not only match the security
that was on prem but then also get
several of these other constructs that
they could not probably have on prem and
they're also one of our users of cloud
armor and they've been using it to
protect internet-facing services so with
this we come to the end of this demo
slash webinar yeah but we really
appreciate everyone who's been writing
in those live Q&A questions so we'll
take just a second compile those
questions and we will be back
you
awesome well thank you so much everyone
for writing in your questions we really
appreciate it
so projector you're in the hot seat have
some questions for you first off what
types of companies are gonna be
interested in clone armor I think that's
a great question and actually the first
question that we should answer I would
say any company organization that's
delivering anything that's internet
facing in Google cloud is going to be
interested in cloud armor one of the
examples that we described was the Black
Friday so we do have a large set of
retailers that are deploying cloud armor
already testing it out and also
deploying it for production traffic
similarly we have a large set of gaming
customers that are interested in this we
have financial customers and also
several large and mid-sized enterprises
because one of the nice things is as
enterprises move to the cloud they have
fast you know started thinking about
pervasive security and this place then
into essentially securing any of their
internet-facing services so at this
point I would say almost everybody who
has I think any plans of delivering an
internet facing service or is delivering
an internet facing services would be
interested in cloud armor awesome
basically everyone who has a website and
more yeah and more and more III also
love that you you mentioned project
shields a little bit earlier so besides
just the pro the for-profit countries we
also support nonprofits so that's
culturally that is true so one of the
things that I had I mean I'm I probably
didn't speak enough about it but we do
have project shield which is essentially
a pro bono service it defends all of the
journalists who are you know it maybe
they're not in democratic nations or
they're under fire for publishing posts
and we use the same Google
infrastructure to actually go defend
their websites so we can actually go and
continue to support freedom of speech
and expression yeah that's a great point
awesome
okay well let's move on to the next one
so I know that Google is very focused
around machine learning and AI for
anyone who joined us at Google i/o I
think that was pretty evident so what
are Cloud armours strategies for
incorporating ml and AI that's a great
question again so ml or machine learning
deep learning these are basically
married in Google's infrastructure at
all layers and so the things that are
under the hood already incorporate
machine learning and AI one of the
things that we want to do is so what is
our vision for cloud armor or any
security system for that matter you want
to make that system more and more
intelligent to a point where there is no
human that's crafting rules or
essentially there is not a third party
that's sitting and monitoring you to
craft rules right at least something
should be aiding them in going and doing
those things and so our vision for cloud
armor or for a lot of our security
systems is can they become intelligent
enough to predict attacks and then they
can they actually go and mitigate those
attacks and there is there are several
initiatives where these things already
exist under the hood but a lot of our
focus for cloud armor will be actually
building it out in a way that our
customers can leverage it as well
so it is a lot roadmap cool sounds good
here the next question is absolutely
applicable I've had a couple customers
asking about it so let's say that you're
a customer you already have a partner
who's helping you with this can they use
cloud armor in tandem with that partner
oh definitely so we have several use
cases it would essentially boil down to
what it is that you want what are the
capabilities that you're looking for we
have several customers who use their
favorite partner and then they combine
that with let's say a blacklist
whitelist using cloud armor they
definitely leverage the DDoS
infrastructure DDoS defense that comes
with a global load balancing and then
they mix and match up all of these so
for instance there might be some
sophisticated or custom baffles that the
partner is built you can definitely use
those in conjunction with cloud armor ok
and can you share any details around
performance I sure so one of the things
where we always do well on all of Google
cloud services is performance and the
reason for that is these are architected
to be distributed systems and so if you
think of the global HTTP HTTP load
balancer we published a blog post two
years back where we tested it with about
a million queries per second which is
huge and beyond that we stopped because
that's way more than what a typical
customer can expect to see the same
applies for cloud armor as well because
it works with the global issue
be HTTPS load balancer and so the global
HTTP HTTP performance again is
applicable to cloud armor as well okay
and then one last question real quick
can you describe the pricing of cloud
honor so the pricing will go effect at
in effect at GA but right now we have
already published it so it's five
dollars for a policy it's $1 for a rule
irrespective of what kind of rule it is
and then it's 75 cents for a million
queries we will be publishing more
details as we get close to the g8 eight
awesome well thank you everyone for
joining us prashanta huge thank you for
for joining us missing chat it's my
pleasure thank you everyone
yeah thanks make sure you stick around
our next session is gonna be around
cloud Composer if you're using anything
Big Data any complex pipelines you'll
definitely want to tune in for that
thanks everyone thank you
you